during the 2016 campaign Donald Trump
made a strong anti-crime case he argued
that high crime communities
needed more police not fewer and that
murder had jumped dramatically in the
wake of Barack Obama soft on crime
policies Department of Justice targeting
of Police Department's and
administration tolerance for anti police
riots in major cities across the country
the media critiqued Trump specific
claims they claimed that he was
exaggerating the rising crime problem in
the wake of what Heather McDonald has
called the Ferguson effect but Trump's
overall message was absolutely right
while the left claimed the crime rates
were doing fine had been dropping for
decades they neglected that murder rates
rose in America cities over the past
couple of years after a sustained drop
and violent crime rates have risen in
America's thirty biggest cities today
The Wall Street Journal reports quote
homicides rose in most big American
cities in 2016
continuing a worrisome trend for police
and criminologists that began last year
even as murder rates in most cities are
nowhere near the levels of two years ago
Trump actually took crime seriously
during the campaign during the RNC he
stated quote decades of progress made in
bringing down crime are now being
reversed by this administration's
rollback of criminal enforcement this
was smart strategy as I said at the time
Clinton by contrast ran on the notion
that mass incarceration was the big
problem that the system was implicitly
biased and that her husband's plans to
lower crime which were actually wildly
successful they had to be dismantled no
wonder she lost Republicans ought to run
on crime regularly across the country
that's how Republicans can get elected
in places like California and New York
remember Richard Riordan Andrew Lee
Julie Rudy Giuliani well Trump did and
he did well in states that have seen
unrest over policing in crime Wisconsin
of course he won saw riot in Milwaukee
Michigan has seen continuing controversy
over crime in Detroit Pennsylvania has
seen high rates of crime in Philadelphia
it's telling that Trump isn't talking
about one of Republicans top legislative
priorities before his election a
criminal justice reform that's good news
given that notions of mass prison
release seem ill-founded in light of
America's rising crime problem Trump
sees something a lot of other
Republicans don't crime matters and so
does safety and he's gonna stand up
against both I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
okay so tons to get you today here on
the Ben Shapiro show by the way I am
gonna be hosting Mark Levin again this
evening so that should be a lot of fun
anyone want to check that out before we
go any further have say hello to our
advertisers as hint water hint water so
hint water is just it's delicious stuff
you go to hints.com slash ben and you
get this pretty major discount it's
normally $24 for a variety packs and
includes three bottles of hints for most
popular flavors which are pineapple
watermelon Crisp Apple and Blackberry
and the great thing about hint is that
it has no calories and it's not full of
non-organic stuff it it actually is
great for kids and it tastes better than
water so water is kind of boring you get
tired of drinking it it's why I've been
drinking sparkling water for a long time
but sparkling water apparently in that
great for your bones is what I've been
hearing actually and hint water is a
different thing it actually allows you
to it allows you to enjoy enjoy water
without the calories and you get this
this great taste of flavor and the
flavors are really good for 15 bucks you
can get the the the variety pack at
drink hint com / Ben that's drink hint
com / Ben and you get that for 15 bucks
instead of the normal $24 give it a try
your family's gonna get addicted to it
it really is great my wife loves it my
kids love it I really enjoy it hint
water drink hint calm / Ben make sure
you use the slash Ben for about the
discount and so that they know that we
sent you okay so lots going on here in
the world that usually there's a
slowdown prior to prior to Christmas but
the news seems to continue to be coming
fast and furious and most of the news
seems to be that the left has lost
utterly lost its mind they are
absolutely crazy towns now the latest
evidence that the left have lost their
minds trumped arrangement syndrome now
roams free across the nation it's like
the stand
somebody says Trump and then the next
person says Trump and eventually they're
all bleeding through their noses and
Keeling over Trump derangement syndrome
has taken over everything the latest
victim of Trump derangement syndrome are
these crazy gay dudes who decided to
confront Ivanka Trump at an airport now
as somebody who's you know has a
relative level of notoriety I see a lot
of people at airports who are fans
like the last few times I've been in an
airport I've seen people who are fans of
the show
is great and there are sometimes people
who disagree and come up and they're
generally pretty simple about it but you
know it's it's in public places it's not
the time for you to start screaming at
random people who you don't like
politically if I saw Barack Obama at the
airport
I would not be tempted to walk up to
Barack Obama and start screaming at him
for his Iran deal it just seems like a
bad breach of kind of common sense
protocol there plenty of good venues to
confront Barack Obama at the airport
doesn't seem like one of them
it's amazing how basic civility has gone
by the wayside what happened is that the
Internet has I think created this
feeling of incivility because you can
hide behind anonymity even if your
name's out there on the Internet
you're not actually speaking to someone
face to face so you can say whatever you
want and that allows people to say
things they would never say in person
see what differentiates me from a lot of
other folks is pretty much everything
I'd say I say on Twitter I also say
directly to human beings but most of the
things that get said on Twitter are
things that people don't say directly to
other human beings but as the internet
culture becomes more pervasive those
lines starts to get blurred and so
instead of people just acting like
jackasses on Twitter and then in real
life acting normally and civilly is
bleeding over so here's the story today
the story today is that this one guy
decided that he was going to accost
Ivanka Trump on a JetBlue flights
according to TMZ Ivanka was leaving JFK
she was seated in the coach area of the
plane first of all good for Ivanka Trump
flying coach like really good good for
Ivanka Trump flying coach that's that's
kind of a neat thing to see and she
doesn't look like glamorous Ivanka there
she looks like a normal lady which is
kind of cool and she's flying JetBlue
coach and by the way contrary to common
rumor put out by some of my political
enemies I always fly coach Mahon cos
just sitting there with her kids and
with her with her husband and this guy
rushes up to her and starts yelling your
father is ruining the country and then
starts ranting why is she on our flight
she should be flying private because why
why should she be flying Pratt why's
that necessary she has to be banished to
the private plane Matthieu lasner is the
name of the of the the guy's partner he
says Ivanka and Jared at JFK t5 flying
commercial my husband chasing them down
to harass them but hashtag banality of
evil
really banality of evil and vodka Trump
first well she's a Democrats probably
agrees with you on have your policies
but second of all banality of evil
actually is the idea that a normal
person is capable of doing evil things
well it seems to me that a kind of evil
thing is chasing down random people in
the airport naming where they are if
they're if they are if they're prominent
and then cursing at them
that seems unpleasant and then I love
the fact that Matthew lasner he actually
says they're my husband chasing them
down to harass them not to speak with
them not to ask a question to harass
them that is the entire goal here is to
harass Ivanka Trump and Jared for no
apparent reason and then afterward he
this this guy's partner got tossed off
the flight is the husband I guess got
tossed off the flight and I put that
back up one second and and he and he
then tweeted Ivanka just before JetBlue
kicked us off our flight when a fit of
attendant when a fit
flight attendant flight attendant
overheard my husband expressing
displeasure about flying with trumps and
then he tweeted also Ivanka and Jared on
our flight my husband expressed his
pleasure in a calm tone JetBlue staff
overheard and they kicked us off the
plane well that's not what witnesses
were saying witnesses were saying that
they were disruptive of the flight that
they were being jerks and and that they
were just cursing at Ivanka for no
reason or at least confronting and
harassing Ivanka for no reason and it's
funny what the media run with so the
media again they complain about fake
news fake news this and fake news that
and then they run with a headline that
says these people are tossed from the
plane after talking to Ivanka Trump so
they ignore the first tweet where they
actually say the goal is to harass them
and they ignore the other people in the
plane you say this was disruptive and
then just say Jose is just a talking-to
there's just somebody talking to Ivanka
Trump really really gross stuff and
again demonstrative of the fact that
there are a lot of people who believe
that for the left virtue signaling is
more important than actual virtue virtue
signaling Trump's virtue so signaling to
all their friends on Twitter that they
confronted Ivanka Trump these people
will be the toast of their cocktail
party this evening that's more that's
more important than them actually just
being decent and say not confronting
people in front of their children and
yelling at them about their fathers
which is weird by the way this guy
apparently was carrying his kid when he
did it - so nothing nothing like
dragging your own child into it as well
and this is not uncommon it's becoming a
bigger and bigger thing there's some guy
named
Monsieur vogue his name is Andre Leon
Talley and Marines outro a piece about
him he is a famous designer and he's
been dressing Melania Trump for a long
time and and Melania and Maureen Dowd
interviewed this guy and here is what
she wrote short I have flown here to see
if Andre can shed some light on Melania
the sultry enigma of Trump world the
only reserved member of what is shaping
up to be the most bellicose takeover in
modern times as everyone else rushes in
to blow up the capital as Ivanka shops
for houses in Georgetown and office
space at the White House as headlines
cascade about how Ivanka will be the
real first lady Melania has virtually
disappeared we see more of her
doppelganger on Saturday Night Live than
we do the real slovenian sphinx who is
hanging back in new york so her
ten-year-old son baron can finish the
school year and then the and then when
she talks to to this guy andre and andre
says that he doesn't want to dress
Melania anymore he's not interested in
dressing Melania he says quote you make
the choice to be in Trump land or you
make the choice to eject yourself from
the horror of from plan I've made my
choice not to be part of from plan so I
guess that now it's okay I'm glad to see
that the left is now okay with refusing
your services to people you don't want
to serve that's that's good to know so
if you're a Christian Baker you're not
allowed to say no to catering a same-sex
wedding but if you're a fashion designer
then you're definitely allowed to say no
to love Melania Trump for no reason
other than you think her husband's kind
of a douche so that's good to know that
now they suddenly believe in free
enterprise and your ability to pick your
own clientele that's that's and that's a
nice thing to be aware of but second of
all again it just shows sort of the
pettiness of these folks it's not
because they have a moral principle
they're not going to dress people with
whom they disagree they dress people
with whom they disagree all the time I
assume they have some clients for
Republicans and voted for Trump but the
idea is that he doesn't want his name
linked with Melania Trump horror of
Horrors she might be wearing one of his
dresses first of all I just have a
question is the left to that vindictive
really truly is left at vindictive if
there is a right-wing fashion designer I
don't know if there are if there is a
right-wing fashion designer and that
right-wing fashion designer dressed
Michelle Obama do you think that right
world would go crazy what anybody would
any conservative go we've got to punish
those people for dressing Michelle Obama
I really really doubt it I really doubt
it but apparently these folks are so
rate of the left or so interested in
virtue signaling that they decide that
it's more important to virtue signal
than to just act with with decency and
moderation and again not the not the
only not the only story like I see
Anthony Bourdain who runs this this the
most overrated show on TV parts unknown
he's a celebrity chef and he goes around
eating food in different parts of the
world and pretending we're all friends
it's basically it's a small world except
with food that you can't eat but looks
good and he goes around does the show he
told the foodie focused website eater he
will never eat in restaurateur
alessandro borg on ninis i guess that's
how bourguignon bo are gog noa you try
it new sushi restaurant at trump's hotel
adding he has utter and complete
contempt for a bull gog noni
and then he took a shot in another chef
David Burke for taking over Jose Andres
planned restaurants in the hotel after
Andres pulled out in protests my films
comments about Mexican immigrants and
now he's really really angry with these
two chefs because he thinks that their
motivation is to get in good with the
President and make money because that's
never motivated anybody on the left to
get in good with Obama and make money I
can thin you Bourdain doing a show with
Obama that wasn't designed to getting
good with Obama and make money
heaven forbid he was just doing it
because he thought it would be you know
really great TV so the left is going
nuts they've decided they can't have any
anything to do with folks on the right
there's a story the other day that said
that the person who was unfriending
everybody on Facebook his Democratic
women's Democratic women are really
pissed and if they see anybody who voted
for Trump or as a Republican their
unfriending them on Facebook which gives
the lie to this idea that it's you're
intolerant John Lithgow from Footloose
uncle who is who's the source of all the
discomfort in your family honest I've
never seen that maybe it exists but I've
never seen maybe because I'm a minority
in our extended family where Republicans
and everybody else is a Democrat but
from where I said it seems precisely the
opposite it seems like most of the
people at Thanksgiving dinner or
Christmas dinner who decide to make it
trouble it seems like those people are
on the left and they want the fight
because it makes them feel good it makes
them feel morally superior okay so if
they can't come up with stories so how
do they justify the sort of behavior how
does the left justify this sort of
behavior saying that it's okay to treat
people this way to confront if Vaughn
could Trump on a flight how do they how
do they make
don't feel better for doing that well
they simply say that they're just
hitting first right there they're trying
to retaliate for the evils and the
intolerance of people on the Trump side
of the aisle and that's why we've seen
the spate of hoaxes there's been this
big spate of hoaxes so for example
there's this story that came out
yesterday there was a Mississippi church
that was burned and somebody
spray-painted on the side of it vote
Trump and here's a picture of what that
church looks like so is burned out
obviously and somebody spray-painted
vote Trump out and the media if you
recall made a huge deal out of this
oh my goodness must've been some crazy
Trump Trump voter who was trying to
intimidate this historically black
church according to the Associated Press
quote a Mississippi man with a prior
criminal record was arrested Wednesday
in the burning of an african-american
church that was spray-painted with the
words vote Trump and the church's Bishop
said the man is a member of the
congregation mm-hmm the State Fire
Marshal said investigators do not
believe the fire was politically
motivated but there are signs it may
have been done to appear that way Andrew
McClinton 45 of Leland Mississippi is
scheduled to make his initial court
appearance
he's charged with first-degree arson in
a place of worship according to the
Mississippi Department of Public Safety
McClinton by the way is a member of the
church he is also black so everybody was
saying that it had to be some white
Trump supporter who burned out this
church because as we all know Trump
supporters are evil racists and
therefore we have to ensure that we have
to we have to crack down on the Trump
people and be mean to them except that
was a hoax other hoaxes so we now know
that this this story at University of
Michigan in which this girl claimed that
in the days after Trump's victory she
stalked by an intoxicated guy who ran up
to her forced her to take off her hijab
and threatened to light her on fire with
a lighter if she didn't that turns out
that that was complete nonsense as well
and our Burt police say the whole attack
was a sham according to the Daily Caller
police lieutenant Matthew leash
announced that officers reviewed many
hours of surveillance footage from the
area where the supposed attack occurred
not only were they unable to find any
evidence of the attack they were also
unable to find any evidence the student
was in the area at the time the attack
also had no eyewitnesses so that too was
a hoax
so hoaxing hoaxing everywhere hoax and
then there's this other hoax that's been
getting all sorts of attention
because here's the thing with the left
if the story is too good to check they
just run with it so there's this this
Muslim YouTube hoax artist and that's
what he does he does hoaxes and pranks
named Adam Saleh and in Salah yesterday
released this video of himself on truck
on on Delta and he was suggesting that
he was thrown off the plane because his
mom was talking to somebody in Arabic
here's a little bit of the video he
released he said this the Facebook or
Twitter guys we spoke a different
language on the plane and now we're
getting kicked out that's insane
now we're gonna kicked out we're getting
kicked out because we spoke a different
language is it this is 2016 2016 look
Delta Airlines are kicking us out he
claimed that this was it this is what
happened and now it's turning out that
the evidence tends to suggest that this
was not true he's a professional
Hulkster this is he made headlines a few
years ago if you remember by claiming
that he squeezed into a tiny suitcase
and flew in the baggage hold from
Melbourne to Sydney and that of course
turned out to be absolute nonsense
he's done this apparently he tried to
pull the same prank on a different
airline this is a that I guess reports
are out today that he was trying to pull
this plant prank on a different airline
earlier and the entire media ran with it
the entire media suggested that that
Delta had thrown him off the flight
because he was speaking Arabic or his
mom with speaking Arabic passengers on
the plane they say that this is nonsense
they say the day that the he was kicked
off the plane for other reasons
apparently the apparently one of the
passenger says that this is not correct
so according to a witness quote I was
sat two seats away from the internet
prankster and his friend neither of them
was on any phone call I could hear them
talking and play in American English the
YouTube guy was trying to get his friend
to shout something in Arabic what you
did a total of four times he shouted
across the plane and the first two times
I thought he was shouting maybe a friend
or something a couple of passengers
after the second time said they were
making themselves and their young
children uncomfortable and could they
shut up they told her to shut up and
then he shouted it again they were
filming people's reactions on their
phone I assume for some comedy YouTube
video but they were made to delete it
Delta said in a statement it appears the
customers who were removed sought to
disrupt the cabin with provocative
behavior including shouting this type of
conduct is not welcome on any Delta
flight while one according to the media
reports as a known prankster
video recorded and encouraged by his
traveling companion what is paramount to
Delta is the safety and comfort of our
passengers and employees it is clear
these individuals sought to violate that
priority then Sullivan claimed that what
they did was wrong and we deserve to
speak up about this he said yes we're
pranksters and it sounds like the boy
who cried wolf but today you can clearly
see us as real as it gets well no I
can't no I can't I mean where's the rest
of the video why is the video start with
them being removed from the plane their
YouTube pranksters why is it that half
these videos start after the incident
and then the media takes the account as
though it was totally cool
they take the accounts as though it's
totally and absolutely relevant and true
that's the fake news that's that's the
real fake news well we have to break
here for a second say hello to our
advertisers over at sea so calm so if
you are really into comedy and this has
been a pretty dark you're in a lot of
ways although I think it's ending well
if you want if you're very into comedy
and you want to watch as much comedy as
you can over the Christmas break you
need to go to see SOCOM and subscribe
for $3.99 a month it is fantastic all
the catalog of all the old comedies
they've got full catalog of Monty Python
of the office the British version they
have classics like 30 rock and Parks and
Rec I'm a big Parks and Rec fan and
Saved by the Bell
I mean they they have they've just you
have to check out their catalogue and go
to see SOCOM and check it out it really
is great they have all sorts of they
have all sorts of different genres as
well everything from the sketch and
stands up and improv to late night
comedy and mockumentaries and you can
spend hours just watching the comedy
here see SOCOM 399 a month my wife and I
really enjoyed the bunch of original
series as well they have one that
actually makes fun of Anthony Bourdain
which is which is great it's a it's
called hidden America with Jonah ray
anything that makes fun of Anthony
Bourdain I'm all in favor of as you may
have noticed see so calm and you make
sure that use promo code Ben if you do
that then they give you two free months
and so that is an awesome DLC socom
promo code Ben 399 a month to subscribe
ok so the so all these hoaxes have had
the predictable effect and that is
they've created this impression the
country is deeply deeply divided when
the truth is a lot of these stories are
just not true and it's driving people to
do crazier and crazier things Trump
derangement syndrome is driven by actual
fake news I just gave you a bunch of
examples of the action
fake news and it's driving people to be
crazy here's another story like this a
group of artists have now come together
demanding that Ivanka Trump removed
their artwork from her New York City
apartment the artists who formed the
halt
Action Group have initiated the dear
Ivanka Instagram campaign as a way to
protest president-elect Donald Trump
through his daughter so there they're
asking her to remove all the art from
her apartment her answer should be go
screw yourself I bought it I owned it
and you can't ask me to do anything with
it really obnoxious stuff coming from
the left if you want to continue to
polarize America along these lines then
please continue doing what you're doing
well as we continue over at Daily
wired.com we're going to continue over
their unfortunate this brings us to the
end of our Facebook live feed we have a
lot more to get to including Donald
Trump's response to the terror attacks
we're going to talk about what I think
is actually the big story of the day
which is Trump is now pushing executive
action for tariffs which is crazy towns
and we're gonna get to a little bit of
Bible talk a little bit later on here on
the program we have to go to daily wire
to do that if you subscribe to daily
warrior $8 a month then that will get
you access to daily wire calm you get to
check out the rest of this podcast alive
you get to be part of the mailbag we're
doing an episode tomorrow so we'll do
the mailbag tomorrow getting your
questions now you buy an annual
subscription for $8 a month and you get
a free copy of my book true allegiance
and what you've been doing really well
get a some free signed copy of my book
true allegiance lots of goodies coming
in the daily wire store soon so make
sure that you subscribe now daily
wire.com and join us the biggest
conservative podcast in the United
States
[Music]
you